Britain's newly minted Prime Minister is
making his debut in Parliament as we
speak an animated Boris Johnson has been
fielding questions from a noisy House of
Commons with both cheers and jeers
directed his way to London now and
Archie Shara and words - deform or
shoddy uh does he look the part
absolutely he does look the part but
actually what we're seeing is that it
was his first speech as Prime Minister
and that message of delivering brexit do
or die by October 31st was clearly
resonating again today in his hardline
speech what Boris Johnson was saying is
that delivering the will of the people
is absolutely about restoring faith in
democracy and in order to do so in the
98 days that the UK has left in the
European Union the UK must actually
turbocharged those No Deal brexit
preparations withdrawal agreement
negotiated by my predecessor has been
three times rejected by this house its
terms are unacceptable to this
Parliament and to this country I hope
that the EU will be equally ready and
that they will rethink their current
refusal to make any changes to the
withdrawal arrangement
if they do not if they do not we will of
course have to leave the UK without an
agreement under Article 50 well he did
also say that he would try and pursue a
new deal with the European Union but as
we know that's much easier said than
done especially taking into
consideration
Teresa Mae's numerous doom deals and
failed attempts in Parliament not to
mention of course the fact that the
European Union has repeatedly and
consistent consistently said that their
withdrawal agreement is not up for
renegotiation now Johnson's first speech
of pushing this crashing out of the bloc
agenda has really angered many mps
across the house who have threatened
Boris Johnson that they will do anything
to stop him in those tracks country is
deeply worried that the new Prime
Minister overestimates himself people do
not trust his Prime Minister to make the
right choices for the majority of people
in this country the Prime Minister has
no plan he is full of bluster but the
consequences of his Fantasyland who have
devastating consequences he is deluded
now there were other moments that caused
some controversy from Boris Johnson's
speech particularly when he said that
the United Kingdom would be the greatest
and most prosperous economy across
Europe by 2050 not to mention of course
that we'll be looking back at this point
in time and this point in history as a
beginning of the new golden era that's
something that MPs across the house also
slammed as fantasy and lunacy but other
points of contention though of course
the fact that the Prime Minister Forrest
Johnson has appointed a very hard right
cabinet in fact it's been coined as the
hardest right cabinet since the 80s
which was of course Margaret Thatcher's
era comes after half the cabinet either
resigned or was sacked and what we're
seeing there is it's a very radical
clear out or to pursue this No Deal
brexit scenario so it's just less than
48 hours since Boris Johnson has been
handed the keys to number 10 and he's
already staring up and causing quite an
impact
Sadia Edwards dasht-e reporting live
from London thank you
you